nach einem monat wartezeit nach
unzähligen kommentaren und instagram
nachrichten geht es heute endlich weiter
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge von rolex trader
endlich geht es weiter mit einer neuen
rolex trader folge ich probiere heute
mit secondhand fashion geld zu verdienen
ich habe eben ein ende letzten jahres so
tik tok videos gesehen wo leute quasi
missouri boxen mit secondhand
festgestellt haben ich dachte das wäre
ein cooles thema hat mich sofort auf die
suche gemacht und diverse pakete
bestellt warum mache ich das video jetzt
also im april die sachen für drei monate
im zoll ich konnte nichts machen jetzt
ist es aber endlich soweit und ich habe
die pakete hier ich habe aber nicht nur
mystery boxen bestellt sondern auch hand
packt sachen bestellt das bedeutet ich
konnte mir quasi bei denen über facetime
selber aussuchen was ich haben will
nichtsdestotrotz zwei pakete komplett
voll mit sachen wo ich keine ahnung habe
was drinnen ist ein paket mit sachen die
ich mir selber ausgesucht habe die
probleme in den nächsten tagen dann über
kleider kreisel vielleicht eine insel
saite und über ebay kleinanzeigen zu
verkaufen und damit das große geld zu
machen insgesamt ist unser stand gerade
so viel so viel habe ich ausgegeben für
diese secondhand sachen und deswegen ist
der herzige stand so und hier haben wir
sie jetzt schauen wir erstmal was wieso
bekommen das hier machen wir mal ganz
zum schluss ich auch weil wir wirklich
nicht wissen was wir bekommen
tatsächlich konnte ich mir eine
kategorie auswählen ich habe einmal
schreckens bestellt brände trek fans
also nur markenfans einmal nur ein
dickes sachen und einmal die sachen die
ich mir selber ausgesucht habe und das
hier sind die hemden sehr nice gut dass
wir sind halt sachen mit den wirklich
niemand etwas anfangen
eigentlich kann ich direkt auf sortieren
das ist cool sehr gut
das sind wahrscheinlich die sachen mit
denen man den verlust von den anderen
wieder raus holen jetzt max hat sich
gerade eine west vorgestellt in komplett
schwarz das ist so dass irgendjemand
bock drauf hat california department for
the fire protection
all in all war die dgfm mystery boxen
absoluter erfolg ich komme direkt ein
hemd an max verkaufen und die restlichen
sachen drin waren waren auch dunkelblau
schwarz eigentlich alle farben die dabei
sind gerade aber ist gut dann kann man
direkt aussortieren und das ist die idee
war und was in dieser sekunde noch
schien wie eine absolute schnapsidee
sollte sich zum ende des videos als sehr
sehr smart entweder hier sind die brände
trek fans oder die sachen die ich selber
ausgewählt habe
das sind die brände trek fans also ist
wieder mystery box was sehe ich dafür
label alter
das sind genau die sachen die wir
brauchen ismaik auch apples keine hose
jordan hose mit so roten stripes an der
seite hps geht weiter mit sweat an die
ich selber ausgewählt habe drive lorena
afrika strip jetzt geht es endlich los
von diesem coachees teils metern habe
ich eine menge gekauft jetzt zum sommer
hin auch wenn wir in diesem moment klar
geworden ist dass ein bisschen frisch
gekauft habe bei der großteil doch immer
noch sehr sehr gut und ich wusste dass
wir den ein oder anderen euro verdienen
werden kann
nike regenjacke schwarze dicke jacke das
ist der nice ich glaube diese sachen
werden richtig gut funktionieren sie
komplett es aus ist jetzt nichts was ich
selber tragen würde
aber ich glaube dass sowas von leuten
gesucht wird die secondhand sachen
kaufen
der nike jacke finde ich noch eine neue
jacke finde ich auch nike indiana rudy
styles wetter
egal was zum habe ich hier gekauft
reebok hause fühlt sich gut an
wie heißen noch mal startet auch gut aus
ja wenn der 50 jährige vater zum
volleyball spielen geht einmal die woche
mit den altherren ist es ganz gut
ansonsten eher schwierig obwohl wir so
stark gestartet sind und am anfang super
peace dabei hatten wurde es zum ende hin
immer schlecht fresh fresh auch
irgendwie träsch sickerwasser ist das
was zum kisters hwk hier das ist ein
fucking tor radhose was ist das alter
zwischen drei monate auf diese pakete
gewartet das ist so eine scheiße der
langsam deutlich größer wird als die
sachen mit dem was anfangen können wie
konnte ich auch irgendwas anderes
erwarten etwas ernüchternd wirklich der
schlechte stapel ist genauso groß wie
der gute stapel
jetzt heißt es aus den guten sachen
möglichst schnell geld machen und aus
den schlechten sachen in irgendeiner
weise noch geld machen damit wir damit
zumindest kein minus machen ich habe da
wahrscheinlich idee wir uns jetzt in
mühevoller kleinarbeit das perfekte
konzept überlegt bilder verkaufen die
müssen also absolut clean werden und wir
dürfen da nur wirklich unsere top
produkte verkaufen um die anderen werden
wir uns dann später kümmern ich habe
also schon die top-produkte aussortiert
ich werde jetzt die schuhe komplett
sauber machen und dann werden wir sap
alle produkte nacheinander
abfotografieren damit dass alles super
clean ist nicht an uns ein kleines
fotostudio zusammengebaut indem er in
mühevoller akkordarbeit alle bilder und
alle klamotten durchgefallen ist alle
bilder fertig bearbeitet sehen super aus
jetzt gilt es natürlich auch noch die
sachen zu verkaufen und ich glaube das
ist sinn machen kann die sachen etwas
hochpreisiger anzubieten einfach weil
man dann das gefühl vermittelt dass es
irgendwelche besonderen sachen sind und
man so ein bisschen über den preis
selber bestimmen kann wie die sachen bei
leuten ankommen höherer preis bedeutet
hochklassige klamotten seltener
klamotten und ich hoffe dass wir so
vielleicht mit diesen einzelnen peace
ist ein bisschen mehr geld herausholen
können die sachen die ich jetzt nicht
einzeln fotografiert habe werde ich in
bunte mix ist zusammentun und dann als
mystery boxen verkaufen ob leute da an
weißen keine ahnung ich lade jetzt
erstmal alle
es ist auf allen plattformen hoch also
kleiner kreisel die porr kleiner zeigen
überall wo man vintage oder second hand
klamotten kaufen und verkaufen kann und
das wird eine menge arbeit wir müssen
uns natürlich auch namen ausdenken der
genau das ausstrahlt was wir ausstrahlen
wollen wir können jetzt keinen
17-jähriger felix sein der irgendwelche
secondhand klamotten verkauft sondern
wir müssen
second wives fabrics second 32 von 36
second time blätterteig steal my
favourite und genau das war die gründung
sekunde vom stil mai fabrik dieser firma
sollte noch großes bevorstehen oder
vielleicht auch nicht
zwei tage sind vergangen und es könnte
nicht besser laufen wir haben
mittlerweile die ersten produkte
verkauft zum einen diese hose diese
jordan rose wurde einfach so ohne dass
mit mir geschrieben oder für 65 euro
verkauft und wir haben 30 nachrichten
offen die jetzt alle beantwortet werden
müssen teil alle leute unsere klamotten
haben wollen das wird super krass und
als allererstes verpacken märz dieser
also wenn ich mir jetzt ein bisschen
mehr zeit nehmen würde wäre glaube ich
der allerschlimmste schritten insta
seite zu machen irgendwelchen instrument
sei die besten sachen zu schicken um
dann werbung über die story von denen zu
bekommen das problem ist ich habe die
zeit nicht dafür und das projekt soll
danach auch nicht weiterlaufen ich will
jetzt keine second and fashion store auf
machen deswegen ist das ein bisschen zu
viel aufwand und ich glaube ich kümmere
mich als nächstes einfach um die mist
gewachsen weil die können tatsächlich
richtig knallen man sagt hier ist dann
gar nichts mehr passiert und ich wusste
ich muss irgendwas tun
in einer nacht und nebel aktion habe ich
gestern abend eine website programm
ich habe keine website programmiert ich
hab die mit sowie fall gebaut aber eine
website gebaut mit shop sale und mystery
die preise habe ich genau so angepasst
dass es für jeden sinn macht eine
mystery box zu kaufen genau so dass sie
nur leicht teurer sind als die einzelnen
pixel so dass der eben noch sachen
reinpacken kann die ich gar nicht
hochgeladen habe damit ich sie auch noch
loswerden
die letzten tage liefen okay wir haben
drei sachen verkauft konnten wieder ein
bisschen geld rein bekommen aber wir
haben drei volle kartons noch hier
stehen also es muss jetzt wirklich noch
was passiert dafür haben wir uns eine
installierung zusammengestellt
[Musik]
vielen dank leo der mich hinter der
kamera und schnitt mir jetzt unterstützt
jetzt werde ich das über den facebook ad
manager auf instagram ausspielen
parallel haben wir noch eine instagram
seite erstellt auf der man alle produkte
sehen kann und dann hoffen wir dass wir
die mystery boxen verkauft bekommen weil
dann verdienen wir geld
ich bin ehrlich richtig kommt die
werbung kann online gehen ich würde wenn
ich das sehen würde ich würde zumindest
die website aufmachen und dann überlegen
je nachdem wie der preis ist die sachen
zu kaufen die mystery boxen kosten jetzt
125 euro und man bekommt fünf pieces
dafür die alle markenkleidung sind also
25 euro pro kleidungsstück das man kauft
das finde ich sehr fair und jetzt kann
das im prinzip online gehen wir haben
die glaube ich ganz gut getarnt auf
leute in jungem alter die passion
vintage fashion interessiert sind und
das tue ich indem ich diese
werbekampagne jetzt aktivieren
geil unsere kampagne online ab jetzt
werden fashion mystery boxen verkauft
let's go
des tages nummer sechs jetzt kommt es
darauf an hat unsere werbung gefruchtet
oder nicht konnten den mystery boxen
verkaufen oder nicht wir haben nur noch
morgen zeitmesser boxen zu verkaufen und
heute ist quasi der tag an dem sich
entscheidet ob unsere werbung wirklich
angekommen ist und das überhaupt sinn
macht das ganze projekt weiter zu machen
ich öffne die shop ich hab nix noch
nicht geguckt bestellung vier stück vier
mystery boxen vier bestellungen über die
letzten vier stunden 125 euro mixed
mystery box ein zweites mal mix mystery
box track band mystery box mix mystery
okay es scheint die am besten zu laufen
wo am meisten glücksspiel mit drin ist
wir haben 500 euro umsatz gemacht
ungefähr 40 euro für die werbung
ausgegeben hat unfassbar gut
funktioniert ich muss aber tatsächlich
wirklich gucken dass ich noch genug gute
sachen habe weil ich ja auch eine gute
misery box anbieten will ich will ja
niemanden abziehen und fünf sachen rein
tun es kann natürlich mal einen nicht
zehn von zehn ps dabei sein und die
anderen sind dafür gut aber da muss ich
jetzt erst mal noch mal zu spät kommen
und checken dass ich genug sachen habe
um alle leute zufrieden zu stellen weil
sie eben auch 125 euro bezahlt haben
wir wussten also dass unser konzept
funktioniert für den siebten tag haben
wir dann alle noch mal die köpfe
zusammengesteckt und alles gegeben was
wir konnten im endeffekt mussten wir
dann trotzdem dem schicksal überlassen
das ganze jetzt nochmal aufgeteilt und
die werbeanzeigen deutlich besser
genauer gestaltet also wir haben eine
kampagne für reichweite eine für
conversion eine für leute die
interagieren sollen eine für leute die
schon interagiert haben also wirklich
eine menge gemacht und das budget noch
mal ein bisschen angehoben weil gestern
abend es gar nichts mehr passiert mit
wissen hoffen dass heute später der ein
oder andere was kauft nach sieben tagen
wirklich den arsch abarbeiten ist es
jetzt endlich soweit wir haben die
sachen auf mehreren seiten eingestellt
haben die website selber programmieren
insta seite gemacht werbungen
eingestellt währungen getaktet und jetzt
ist das grosse finale und wir checken
wie viel wir im endeffekt wirklich
verkaufen kommen
keine
[Musik]
wir haben 16 bestellungen 125 euro 16
mystery box name verkauft 120 euro
reingewinn bei fünf euro versand sind 16
mal 120 euro haben wir damit gemacht wir
haben 200 und 7 euro für die werbung
insgesamt ausgegeben also ist der
aktuelle betragen diese unglaublich ich
glaube wir haben keine rolex trader
folge bisher so viel geld verdient aber
ich glaube ich habe auch noch in keinem
dieser folgen so viel arbeit
reingesteckt wenn ich das video gefahren
hat lass mir gerne leichter vergesst
nicht den kanal zu abonnieren damit ihr
keine folgenden videos mehr verpasst wir
sehen uns nächste woche
lasst euch gut gemischt ist komplett
gestört ich bin am zittern
3000 euro werden die 2000 euro verdient
plus die sachen die wir einzeln verkauft
haben das ist komplett gestört